Hier sind wir!
Deutschland nunmal!
Tut mir Leid! Aber das Ganze war es doch wert
Hey, wie geht es euch? Ich bin Christoph.
Super, wir sind Yosef und Tshawe
Danke fürs Kommen!
Dankeschön! (von beiden)
So, wie fühlt ihr euch denn gerade?
Wir sind ziemlich glücklich hier zu sein,
weil ihr hier in Deutschland
sehr nett zu uns seid, dafür sind wir dankbar.
Das Wetter heute ist Mist, aber innerlich strahle ich.
Wieso ist "Glow" ausgerechnet in Deutschland so groß rausgekommen?
Der Eurovision Song Contest ist in Deutschland sehr populär
und die Auswirkung
die wir auf Deutschland und die Umgebung hatten war einfach nur wunderschön.
Hättet ihr euch vorstellen können so erfolgreich zu sein? Oder kam es eher überraschend?
Ich hatte es gehofft. Man erwartet es einfach nicht, so zu
'explodieren', wie es hier geschah,
aber wir wussten 'das ist ein guter Song', und das was wir gemacht haben,
geradedas  mit dem Flashmob war einmalig und wir waren optimistisch.
Was ging euch durch den Kopf als ihr den Flashmob das erste mal gesehen habt?
Oh mein Gott! Ich habe geweint. Ich war einfach so überglücklich und so emotional,
überglücklich und so emotional,
es ist einfach wunderbar diesen Moment mit einem ganzen Kontinent zu teilen.
Sollte der Song genau dies erreichen, oder war es eine Nachricht?
Wir wollten, dass die ganze Welt zusammen strahlt, und für die 8 Minuten
Europa war 'eins', jeder, Deutschland, Finnland, Norwegen, Schweden, Türkei..
Das war eine wunderschöne Sache und der Song soll genau das repräsentieren.
Und ihr lebt in Norwegen?
Ist das dort dieselbe Situation für alle Menschen?
Wir haben nicht soviele Türken, wie es hier der Fall ist
Wusstet ihr, dass es in Deutschland mehr Türken gibt
als Norweger in Norwegen? Das ist ganz schön verrückt
Aber ich denke das wir eine bessere Perspektive haben
denn in Norwegen wurden Integration und verschiedene Minderheiten
aus irgendeinem Grund zu einem neuen Aspekt.
Es ist nicht nötig die Politik zu berücksichtigen..Es ist alles nur neu
Und alle Leute rasten aus! (im positiven Sinne)
In den letzten 10 Jahren haben sich die Norweger beruhigt
und sehen dass wir nicht gekommen sind um die Regierung zu übernehmen
Und das wir eigentlich ganz okay sind! Ja, es ist ganz cool dort.
habt ihr nach der Show Feedback bekommen
von Leuten die sagen "Gut gemacht, tolle Nachricht!"
Ohja! Die Reaktionen waren einfach überwältigend und positiv.
Nicht nur aus Norwegen, sondern aus Europa als ganzes.
weil es genau das ist, was es repräsentiert
Wir sprechen verschiedene Sprachen und ich schwöre, speziell für Leute
die soviel in verschiedene Länder reisen, Ihr denkt ihr seid alle
verschieden aber in Wirklichkeit sind wir alle gleich.
Also alle Ausländer sind in derselben Situation?
und wir sind auf den größten Teilen der Welt, wir sind alle Ausländer.
Absolut. Selbe Scheiße, verschiedene Toiletten!
Ein toller Satz! Was sind denn eure nächsten Schritte?
Wir sind in Deutschland, wir kommen hier jede Woche her
Im Spätsommer oder im Herbst kommt das neue Album raus
Also werden wir mit Promotion, etc. zurück sein!
Oh, das ist perfekt!
- Wunderschön
Du darfst sitzen!
Und das Schwarze ist für den Schwarzen?
Was bei euch so speziell ist, ist dass viele Leute
Eure Songs, wie z.B. "Beggin" kennen, aber nicht euch
Also habt ihr etwas zu tun um in Europa bekannter zu werden!
Ja, das ist Teil des Jobs, deswegen sind wir hier,
deswegen reisen wir soviel
Die Auswirkung, die "Beggin" das erte mal hatte, war so groß
dass wir da mitgehen mussten, und jetzt an diesem Punkt
mit Glow, unserer neuen Single, wird es besser werden.
Ist es aufgrund der vielen Länder hier schwer, berühmt zu werden?
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle sagen
Ich bin schon lange Single,  und normalerweise war es ein Problem
mittlerweile nicht, ich liebe euch deutsche Frauen. Danke!
Und ich habe gehört ihr habt Interesse
mit Bushido zusammenzuarbeiten?
Einer der bekanntesten Rapper in Deutschland.
Ihr seid auch Rapper, aber Glow ist kein Rap!
Ja, es ist Pop.
Ich kann mich daran erinnern, Bushido getroffen zu haben
Es ist eine Weile her, ich weiß nicht mehr wo
Bei "The Dome", ja. Ich respektiere seinen Style
Und er sieht aus wie ein netter Kerl
Ja, nicht mehr als das.
Aber ihr wollt mit euren Texten Leute zu vereinigen,
zusammenzubringen. Bushido hat aber einen anderen Stil
Er ist mehr..anders
Nein nein,
er wollte 'töten', nein, mehr boxen,
Er ist ein Gangster Rapper.
Und ihr wollt mit ihm zusammenarbeiten?
Ja klar, das wäre verdammt cool.
Ich wäre daran interessiert, worüber wollt ihr denn rappen?
Nicht wie Bushido, Bushido sagt "ich töte",
ich sag "nein nein, wir reden darüber"
Das ist ne gute Idee!
Vielen Dank!